[Music]
venom has arrived and the public just
can't seem to get enough of the world's
most popular brain-eating alien symbiote
but while you were distracted by that
slippery slimy tongue you might have
missed some of the film's more subtle
moments
here's a look at some small details you
missed in venom
source material one thing is very clear
in almost every scene of venom
the people who made the movie are big
fans of the comic book
some of it is pretty obvious like the
fact that the life foundation was front
and center in a number of plot lines
involving the alien symbiotes
but there's plenty beyond that for
instance there's the idea that the life
foundation's original goal was to cure
cancer
that comes from the origin story of the
ultimate marvel universe's version of
venom
then there are specific sequences for
instance the scene where riot
rips venom out of eddie's host body is
an almost exact recreation of the cover
of venom carnage unleashed number three
and there are even specific lines of
dialogue borrowed from the comics like
the line
[Music]
which originally appeared in the pages
of amazing spider-man number 374
creator call outs venom features all
sorts of references to the writers and
artists who created the character
most prominently when eddie's
ex-girlfriend anne mentions the name of
her law firm
mkhilani and mcfarland those names of
course belong to writer david mcelini
and artist todd mcfarlane who co-created
venom in amazing spider-man number 299
but some references are more obscure
near eddie's chinatown apartment for
instance a sign in the background in the
final scene reads
ron lim's herbals which is a reference
to artist ron lim
who penciled the venom lethal protector
miniseries that much of the film is
based on
and the apartment building eddie lives
in that would be the shuler building
named for randy schuler a fan who sent
his idea for a black spiderman costume
to marvel in the 1980s inadvertently
providing the original inspiration for
venom in the first place
nice deadly doggy one of venom's many
funny moments is the all too brief
sequence in the hospital when
separated from eddie brock the venom
symbiote is forced to use a tiny little
doggie named gemini as a host in order
to survive
that's actually a subtle reference to
the comics where not one but
two dogs have been turned into symbiotic
monsters
one was ivan a sled dog while the other
was a german shepherd
named samson both symbiote dogs proved
that when it comes to pet ownership
good breeding does indeed matter so if
you suspect your pet has been bonded
with an alien killer
please consider getting it spayed or
neutered the symbiote scream
at the beginning of the film it's
mentioned that there are five
alien life forms being brought back to
earth one is venom
one is riot who bonds with the movie's
villain carlton drake
one is apparently agony the bluish
symbiote who kills poor doctor dora
skirth before dying itself
and one is probably carnage who may or
may not be attached to serial killer
cletus cassidy by the time the first
post-credit scene hits the screen
but there's also a fifth symbiote who
seemingly vanishes
way through the film the yellow symbiote
who briefly bonds with a super cute
little bunny rabbit
exactly which symbiote this is and what
happened to it are both mysteries but
while some speculate that the bunny
might have housed the symbiote known as
phage the smart money is on another
yellow tinted symbiote
scream in the comics both phage and
scream were created by the life
foundation but scream eventually turned
on the others and killed
all their host forms believing symbiotes
to be evil
given that the film seems to be setting
up venom versus carnage for the sequel
having a loose canon like scream at
large and looking to eliminate both of
them could be a fun
and interesting twist the wilhelm scream
it's not just comic book fans that got
serviced with in jokes
movie buffs also got their own call out
thanks to the prominent use of the
legendary wilhelm scream during the
scene where venom fights the swat team
the audio was actually first used way
back in 1951 for the film the distant
drums during a scene where a man was
eaten by an alligator
named for private wilhelm a character
who gives this pained cry in 1953's the
charge at feather river after being shot
by an arrow
the sound effect was revived in 1977
star wars when a storm trooper fell to
his doom
inside the death star it subsequently
became a tradition for star wars and
indiana jones films and then spread to
everything from reservoir dogs to beauty
and the beast
pretty exciting that venom is keeping
the tradition alive